comment sortir de la dimension totemique
dans laquelle baigne désormais ce débat
une démocratie comme un autre est
capable d'en débattre sereinement même
d'un sujet si clivant et si passionnant
si fondamentalement français nous le
devons se débat aux Français car l'enjeu
est considérable sauvegarder notre
système de retraite pour dégénérations
futures et faire durer faire perdurer le
pacte de solidarité ou en sommes-nous
9 jours de débat l'Assemblée nationale
sans parvenir à l'article 3 des
stratégies d'obstruction et de blocage
20 000 amendements déposés désinfectifs
des violences verbales des menaces et
tout cela en fin de compte tout à
l'heure vous allez regretter que le
texte n'est pas été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale il n'a pas été voté parce que
les parlementaires n'ont pas voulu le
voter et Monsieur Mélenchon lui-même à
travers un tweet a bien demandé au Sénat
aux députés de ne pas voter ce texte
donc ils auraient pu le voter ils n'ont
pas le voulu le voter aujourd'hui ne
veulent pas vous dire qu'ils n'ont pas
vu le voter ici ici revenons au Sénat
revenons au Sénat les
426227 amendement déposé sont-ils les
premiers d'une obstruction au Sénat moi
je me le demande avec 69 avant mes chers
collègues
identiques des trois groupes de la
gauche disons à supprimer l'article mais
liminaire je m'inquiète un peu le
comique de répétition est ses limites
rassurez-vous nous sommes rassurez-vous
69 similaires 69 à moins de moins
similaire le psytacisme ça existe
rassurez
vous nous sommes tous ici pour débattre
pour réaliser ce qui n'a pas réussi à
sembler et se prononcer sur ce texte
après le spectacle désolant du dernière
semaine il appartient au Sénat d'ouvrir
le débat et de le faire avec exemplarité
ce sera difficile parce que c'est
exigeant politiquement tranché mais
respectueux je sais les oppositions
résolues mais j'espère pouvoir compter
sur l'esprit de responsabilité chacun
pour débattre avec sérénité le Sénat
doit montrer que le Parlement est un
espace de dialogue débattre pour
éclairer une délibération et pour voter
notre conviction est que sans cette
réforme et sans consentir à de nouveaux
efforts il n'y aura pas d'avenir
pleinement assuré pour notre système de
retraite ceux qui préfère flatter
l'opinion en ayant la nécessité de cette
réforme condamne notre système même par
répartition quels alternatives chers
collègues une baisse des pensions
impensable une hausse de cotisation
intenable notre choix nous l'avons fait
c'est la valeur travail le texte qui
nous est présenté aujourd'hui permet un
retour à l'équilibre en 2030 pour y
parvenir un effort de deux années
supplémentaires et demander aux Français
répartis de manière juste en tenant
compte de la situation de l'oppositoyens
ils plus vulnérables de ceux et ceux qui
ont commencé plus tôt de la pénibilité
des Carnières hachées des pistes
d'amélioration sont encore possibles
notre groupe porte plusieurs en
plusieurs noms au nom de la justice
sociale je pense au rachat du trimestre
pour les stages et les études je pense
aussi à leur revalorisation des pensions
de retraite et de l'ASPA à Mayotte je
tiens à saluer ici le travail décisif de
nos secteurs Mahorais notamment notre
métal ici sur ce sujet
[Musique]